when you think about making a vaccine
this probably isn't what you had in mind
[Applause]
this soupy concoction is being made in
thailand to combat covet 19. and the key
ingredient
tobacco plants
so it takes only 10 days for us to
produce a prototype and another like no
more than three weeks to test whether
that prototype work or not like for
example right now we already work on the
all micron strains already we have the
prototype and we're testing it right now
the low nicotine tobacco isn't the kind
used in cigarettes
the harvested leaves act as a host to
produce proteins which mimic the covid19
virus
they're blended and the protein is
extracted
the resulting vaccine stimulates
antibodies which our bodies can use to
fight coronavirus in the future
hobbit 19 is not going to be the last
one right we're going to have so many
emerging diseases
and
if we can develop the vaccine ourselves
then we can have like um
we don't have to rely on the vaccine
from other countries
the clinical trials are still ongoing so
growing conditions are tightly
controlled
if successful this facility could
produce 60 million plant-based covered
vaccines a year
the first of its kind in asia
the benefit of these tobacco plants
particularly for low-income countries is
you can grow them almost anywhere you
don't have to have a fancy lab and it
takes just one month to turn them from a
seed into a vaccine
even if it all goes to plan the earliest
the vaccine will be ready is late next
year
but once perfected this tobacco-based
technology is adaptable
we can use it to produce other drugs so
we can use it to produce anti-cancer
anti-rabies anti-venoms and those
we will focus on more like tropical
diseases that normally um you know
multinational pharmaceutical family
might not be interested in
these little plants are providing a
growing number of opportunities
helping countries like thailand to
develop their own weapons to fight
deadly diseases siobhan robbins sky news
bangkok